if I'm gonna die and two weeks later  they're going to forget about me do I  really care what they think about my  clothing so I just don't think it  matters if I'm wearing a beater or like  nice shoes just like am I comfortable in  this does it serve the functions that I  want like so for me it's like I have to  be able to get into restaurants wearing  it I have to be able to work out in it  and I have to be able to like work in it  and to be cool and like the reason that  I wear the flannels most times is like I  can go from pretty hot if I button  everything all the way down to like  varying levels of less heat to taking it  off and I still haven't undershirt  because otherwise if I just had that and  I'd be shirtless and I wouldn't be able  to go out in public but like even with  these I can like kick these off under  the table because that's apparently  something that I do a lot I get hot a  lot that is functional for me